well there could be some more sharp
swings for Facebook stock following its
latest bombshell a leaked memo from a
top executive is raising new concerns
just how far the social media giant is
willing to go to boost its profits and a
Warner has the story in the June 2016
memo Facebook executive Andrew Bosworth
wrote that Facebook connecting people
can be good and bad maybe it costs a
life by exposing someone to bullies
Bosworth wrote maybe someone dies in a
terrorist attack coordinated on our
tools he continued the ugly truth is
that we believe in connecting people so
deeply that anything that allows us to
connect more people more often is de
facto good Bosworth sent the memo three
days after a man in Chicago was shot
dead during his Facebook live broadcast
after the memo was made public Thursday
Bosworth posted a statement on Twitter
saying I don't agree with the post today
and I didn't agree with it even when I
wrote it the purpose of this post he
wrote was to bring to the surface issues
I felt deserved more discussion with the
broader company Facebook CEO Mark
Zuckerberg responded Baz is a talented
leader who says many provocative things
but he said this was one that most
people at Facebook including myself
disagreed with strongly we've never
believed the ends justify the means
wired magazines Nick Thompson his
comments about growth that growth is
everything it was rare and fascinating
to see a Facebook executive say that so
bluntly for CBS this morning Saturday
Anna Werner